foreign
I just started going to therapy is it
always so draining and emotional
no you wrote that question in dang it
thank you
for putting that question in Jenna
um no it is not
uh depending on why you went to therapy
and what you and your therapists are
working through
um
I mean it's just like going to the gym
there's times you go to the gym and it
is miserable and or you want to lose 30
pounds that first I mean getting back
into the swing of things is hard it's
draining you just leave all beat up and
in short order you start leaving the gym
with tons more energy my workout this
morning was brutal and I left just
electrified and I feel so good man and
so uh there will be Seasons when you
leave the counselor counselor and you
cannot wait to go Take On The World
you've got some new tools you're able to
process some things you feel lighter so
you feel good
um but at the beginning when you're just
saying some things for the first time
when you are allowing your body to
finally feel some of those things for
the first time the shame the regret the
sadness the Heartbreak the the fear
um the anxiousness all those feelings
you do that for the first time it's
overwhelming that's why having a
therapist is so important because you've
got somebody there with you figuratively
like holding your hand right
um but no it will not be like that
forever stick it out I tell people
unless there's just a clear ethical
violation or a clear like this is a bad
Vibe I am finding myself lying to this
person because I can't be in their
presence
um stick it out three or four sessions
when you go stick it out three or four
sessions get get through that initial
and get to the other side of it
um and that's where the piece is the
only way to heal is doing the hard hard
work is going right through the middle
of it that's it man so great great
question on that one